yeah um we've got uh
his cousin east coast ron jeremy
we got east coast with jeremy this guy's
got a bigger dick
and more come oh which is weird no
felonies though yeah no felonies a lot a
lot of calm
rod felony isn't it well he's a stand-up
he's a oh play on words
and i enjoy it so we've got um you know
white guys
let me talk about white guys white
comics
[Applause]
it's so hard like when i started doing
stand-up
in the 90s and it was as an asian guy
in la or you know what originally san
diego it was very difficult i felt like
because i was the only one that looked
like me
people it just it didn't feel like i
could be a part of it right
i also knew that i wasn't the right
color yet yeah yeah
you can sami sosa yourself yeah i wasn't
the right color yet
ah yeah i mean and um because i had an
agent tell me
when i first moved to la i can't rep you
because you're never gonna work
he literally said that i could say his
name i'm not going to because he's still
in the business but um
i want to call him out but i'm not gonna
um but he was with icm
all right let's move on and so um
but then it's like now you know cancer
culture
things have changed you know i mean you
know immigrants are being
put in the front kind of right i'm
getting more work
now which is cool but um so i find what
you're not an immigrant by the way
where are you you're just korean
american
i know you didn't come here on a vessel
can i
i just want to be with you okay you want
to be an immigrant with me i i'm just
saying you know okay go ahead you don't
have to call that out that's
okay you're right you can be an
immigrant if you want all right so and
as
us immigrants you know i mean me too
struggled so hard to get here
um anyway so when a white guy you know
to create a name as a white comic male
especially
is so [ __ ] difficult
like i would like maybe 30 years ago i
would love to i would love to been a
jewish guy or a white guy in comedy but
it's just so hard so
when a white guy makes a name for
himself right
in this climate they're extra good
they know they really are not i'm not
i'm not blowing steam up this guy's ass
right i'm just stating a fact around
jeremy from east coast okay
lots to come so what i'm saying is is
that when i see
you know a white dude make a name for
himself in this climate they're just
there's just something extra about them
and it's a little if they're um
resilient right
and they they cross you know i mean
certain borders
and whatnot and people identify with it
and it's very difficult
and this is one of them this guy um i
never you know because he lives in new
york we never cross paths
i think i i i said hi to him once but he
maybe ignored me but
but um it's fine it sounds like him yeah
it sounds like him but um
we've never really crossed paths but
i've been a fan from afar
you know he's a very funny stand-up and
um he's doing very well
for himself and um he's done all the
late night shows
you know podcasts done all of them he's
um
he's great and his name is mark norman
give him a round of applause
[Music]
finally somebody talk about how hard the
white man's got it
yeah thank you wow that was very nice
and weird and i can't take a compliment
but i appreciate why why can't you take
a compliment
well i don't trust asians but no
no it's weird thank you it means a lot
yeah yeah
thanks thank you but you have to admit
though that it is you but you know
you know that the culture is changing
sure
worse and so i'm not really supposed to
say it but i know you're not supposed to
say
i'm just going to tell you it well we
talk about it at the meetings
all right the white meetings that you
have yeah yeah who's at those white
meetings the rallies
you know it's uh are there other
comments there yeah it's me owen
benjamin and a couple other guys
no yeah yeah yeah do you ever run into
owen no
i don't know i don't know i don't really
know him but mark you have to admit
though
you you're doing well it's going well
finally
like i'm selling tickets well you know
the game has changed i've done 13 late
nights and all this [ __ ] nobody cares
wow you do three podcasts and people
like hey who's this guy
that's that's how it goes now and this
this op what is this this uh
little ck screen here just in case
that's
nice yeah this is optics it's it's
garage
got it um yeah the late night show i
mean i
even back in the day when i did it i did
the tonight show a long time ago in 2000
or whatever the leno
leno yeah no one one person at a coffee
shop
said weren't you on she goes weren't you
on jay leno doing stand up i go
yeah and she goes okay
i mean like nothing so it's like that's
all i got yeah
it's like that hedberg joke where you'd
say more people saw me at the store
yeah nobody sees it but you know what it
does do though
it it i think it validates you
as a stand-up i guess so it's for you
it's like a resume thing
right but it's also in in the club
atmosphere too you have to admit that
like
maybe you don't have to admit you have
to do do whatever you want to do but um
what i'm saying it's america yeah
and you guys are still in charge
[Laughter]
you know you you know when i before i
did the tonight
show um i was just to stand up doing the
clubs but then it kind of
elevated me you know i mean within the
club right
i got better spots really yeah and
people looked at me
in a different way i guess in terms of
comedy you know
my peers you know and it also helps with
your self-esteem
don't you think yeah it helps and you
get to throw a suit on and it's a big
deal
lights and adults there you know feels
good and you get paid
and you got to work out the set and it's
on tv and you get to tell your mom
so that part's nice yeah but it doesn't
move the needle
it doesn't no it doesn't but um do you
get nervous before
oh i get nervous for everything yeah oh
yeah yeah everything makes me nervous
but that's good you want to get a little
jolt going you know
yeah yeah yeah always uh and nicole
smith you know you're just
one level zoned out that's not healthy
yeah that's true yeah i do love the
feeling of being super nervous
yeah right you're alive right but then
also
can i even do you know hopefully
hopefully i don't mess up